Andrew Goldberg described a data structure that can be used
to very rapidly compute shortest-path distances between nodes in a network.
The way that it worked was each node of the network has a label.
What a label is is a list of other nodes in a network that he called hubs
along with the distance to that hub.
The hubs are chosen for each node,
the labels are chosen for each node,
so that they have the property that for any two nodes in the network,
any two nodes where you want to compute a shortest-path length between them,
will have some hub in common in their labels that is on the shortest path
between those nodes.
Let's make sure that you have a feel for this idea,
and let's look at a particular kind of network--a star network--
where there is one node in the middle and all these other nodes directly connected to it.
How many hubs do we need to list in the labels of each of the nodes in a star network
so that we can make sure that we satisfy this property
that we can compute the shortest path length sufficiently,
specifically because for any pair of nodes in the network
their labels will have some hub in common.
Why don't you type the number into the box.
You can use this particular star network as your example
and give the answer for this star network,
but it turns out it actually works for star networks of any size.